[Music]
so we shall continue with a game between
gashimov and ivanchuk the game actually
played in
2011 couldn't find it online like to
upload it so we'll put it manually and
actually this this was very important
game for Theory and quite quite a cool
game in one of the most complicated line
that somehow karakin actually at that
year karakin was like whatever he was
playing in those lines was just getting
a point so gashimov is white ivanchuk is
Black from rajio Emelia 2011 okay white
has one move here to give advantage or
to fight for Advantage yes I mean there
are so many moves in the position Knight
C3 F3 take so on but yeah I mean they
say that E5 is the most dangerous line
E5 played okay supported by Spencer and
wer Bishop F5 Knight
F3
E6 Bishop E2 okay so you play This
brilliant move order but you get the
bishop
out so somehow it's working yeah and
like there are thousands of complicated
theoretical lining in this position and
really karakin had some of the some of
the best games in this line are by
karakin Queen
B6 Knight
C3 yeah like he take on B2 in some
versions uh here I mean game that is
mentioned yes here in this building was
wasn't like christansen winning like
immediately yeah like the game was you
were talking about this game today me
and
Mar I mean the game was like really fast
right like yeah but okay a is coming in
two and a half weeks so we don't know
what was the result but it was a really
fast
game but uh another model game is karaki
nanov with Queen takes be2 some of the
craziest craziest lines but okay we're
going to look at Knight C6 first and
then
take Queen E1 now if someone's going to
ask me why any of those moves being
played no
comment like just no it's no
comment but Queen E1 I mean this suppos
at least this was super duper High
theory in
2011 take a night take a bishop take
First Take take I mean this is I mean we
can analyze the theory but would miss
our point and Bishop B
before now how to play here for
white that's really interesting
yes and if take
the Knight on C3 let's say with the
queen let's say queen to Rook to B1 and
the queen just take your knight what
will you play
there huh Queen trade Queen trade that
that's that's a that's a very nice trade
but kind of the Knight the Knight like
vanished there
no but Rook B1 was actually
played yeah Rook takes B4 right no in
this it's it's very I mean in the same
if Bishop if Bishop takes C3 also Rook
takes also Rook takes
B4 actually he took with the
bishop they say that it's better to have
I mean look if Bishop
take then The Rook is on B2 somehow
seems not as attractive as having The
Rook on B4 yes
Julian
Bishop B5
check
this queen takes C3 so you want you want
to play
what okay and let's say I
move and now will take but think about
this like what what has this check given
you ah he cannot canastel but that's not
the idea of the position the I mean I
mean you're Pawn down with bad structure
I mean if you cannot break through I
mean black can play like you know I
don't know take
take knight7 Knight HC I don't know okay
let's play
this like if you cannot break through
and do it super quickly you're going to
be in trouble
here
no okay so so what so what will you have
your
maximum I I mean I'm not trying to play
for Advantage here let's say I'll just
play
here take
take
and Ben was now you see I didn't know it
about 30 minutes ago 40 minutes ago I
didn't know 30 minutes ago but after I
understood the end game gim of car that
he get a king on E6 and he has a better
King I would even say that I think maybe
black is better in this end game C2 is
weak the C file the king is
better
no no Julian's point is black can C
Queen side if you don't check and he's
wondering about that okay we we will
look at that yeah maybe he did do that
maybe he did do that okay dramatic I I
remember the game and he didn't do
that so we
took took took took and now
Castle I'm just going to jump on you
here like crazy
no I don't know this move seems a good
start what what if Rook D7 everyone
other than Ben fine
gold cuz this I know he
SE okay maybe he
is I didn't see him there and I was
thinking that okay other than the fine
gold
to that's not bad close but you know
I'll take this as a as an
idea
yeah actually everything is is Right
Knight B5 is good but I like this the
most I think although although maybe
maybe take it I mean okay maybe maybe it
just doesn't matter
like doesn't
matter yeah so so B6 and
now I don't know I just want to play
this
like just a
like A5 you know today I was watching
some videos on YouTube of uh C and no
and I I mean now I'm going to start
imitating him I mean not the way of
playing that's impossible but like the
way of like he's analyzing so he's
saying like A4 A5 and like attack like
he always does this with your hand have
you seen this B like he always like oh
like n okay so that's it
officially but just winning here I think
for white like I don't see what to play
after A5 and this this is just
incredible like just not nothing to
do it's nothing to do here I
[Music]
think maybe maybe Knight E7 and King C7
I don't get the pawn to B6 it opens up
theare but I I want to take it
immediately
it opens up the square for
Knight but but but then maybe Rook D7
protecting the pawn and moving The Rook
from under
attack I mean actually I'm not certain
how to win
here this this
this but no F6 I'm just going to ignore
it I think to get your to6 if you move
your if f yeah I'm going to ignore it
like if we will see that in a second if
I I think I'll just play here and I
know something something like this yeah
maybe the comes up to the knightes the
pawn
check they take what where sorry so
Knight to
C6 actually this is probably best move
maybe I mean some somehow black is not
supposed to to survive something like
that which L do you wanted to say sorry
Knight C6 Knight to after take the
pawn okay and if the Rook goes to let's
say
D6 oh I was going off what you said last
okay Rook D7 ah okay so you believe me
okay so Rook D7 so uh the Knight can
still take Knight takes
A7 takes Now The Rook can come up and
take B6 but but you give you give you
gave me a
piece I'll play this move like oh I'll
just take like okay I mean a piece is a
piece right I mean Knight is a night
I'll make effort to develop a bit
after we don't give material that
freely but I think let's if they mention
this idea at all of Castle no not even
not mentioned at all I mean let's see
what what computer say after long Castle
after long Castle it says Rook a
B1
B6 and now actually he doesn't like he
doesn't like my non brilliant A4 move
huh he likes G4 and KN C6 computer likes
you more you
know he likes you a little
yeah okay just want to win the pawn like
this but A4 not to like what is not to
like A4 okay he's saying white is big
big plus after A4 on the verge of
winning 1.3 but Knight C6 was somewhat
better 1.56 okay not crazy but bottom
line no long Castle White just has
variety of moves over there so here is
the thing Mr Julian you don't play
Bishop B5 when you want to take on B7
like let black fix that
thing so
B6 okay now Bishop
B5 I mean just blocking The Rook
is and here he
played here played King f8 no okay this
is actually important game for T there
were I remember some games that followed
after it I think but what to play after
this move in some way I I find I mean
same similarities like playing
unorthodox like okay Pawn down the
opponent King is tiny bit in danger
and here white is a really strong move
but not very simple one but really
strong actually maybe maybe not really
that strong but
but but Knight C but okay but what what
well what
what okay
out well Bish to okay Rook to E8 maybe
don't want to lose
material
I can actually I can actually Pro
probably this is even
stronger and the bishop doesn't look so
happy over there just King E7 next move
that may be even even
stronger C4 just King E7 or something
like
that no but okay here kind of tricky
position
position I think it's the same idea that
we will see after in the game that I at
least like the most in this
position what will you play
then I was thinking Bishop
a on
yeah amazing amazing but it may
immediately Rook A3 is a tiny B but yeah
very good like that this idea of playing
that positional is very
cool I mean I remember looking at this
game and it's just so impressive that
there's so much pressure here it doesn't
seem like there is really attack
but yeah there just quite a lot
of quite a lot of pressure in some lines
like actually this idea is going
to is going to be
possible like The Rook on the third rack
is a
monster King f8 was played by Ian
chuk take
take and here Rook B3 was played and
there's
some I mean it's amazing this position
is okay for black I mean nanuk lost
quite quickly okay you know it was I
think it was quite new that time and in
a game not so easy to find All the Right
Moves are anyway mve the all
but yeah computer say C4 his best move
or Rook D1 but gashimov took Ben's idea
and play kind of Rook
[Music]
B3 Knight E7 another another idea is
just to get the king away you know just
just get somewhere out with the king I
think it was better than the Knight E7
but okay maybe no big
difference Rook C3 was
played yeah here kind of difficult move
like the same way that Ben suggested
before for white to play Rook
E3 at least I can tell you that
computer's best idea for black is to
activate this rook and how do you
activate this Rook when there is a king
on
f8 both answers are
good you are my new spokesman you know
I'm going that's it you know for every
important meeting or whatever you're
coming that's
it but
H5 that's a way
to get the
Rook
right all righty
well A6 was played and now kind of
surprising move
but surprising but
strong like stick the bishop there like
actually there was now a game I think
car that Carlson beat Anand and the
final position was like he had like
Bishop on D7 like Pawn somewhere on the
E5 and Anan just resigned like there was
no way for the Rooks to fight the bishop
and do anything well this is I mean once
again still nothing dramatic computer is
always like at 02 03 for white
but but it's just you know uncomfortable
to play with being so under so so much
pressure all the time all right H5 was
quite quite important here in getting
the Rook to defend and so on G6 which is
much simpler move was played or it looks
looks simpler but worse yes my question
is why doesn't white bring the uh E Pawn
up to
um E6 to develop to develop the uh The
Rook so you want to open the eile right
it will be he
played two moves very
good very
good but by the way if white will play
E6 let's say theoretically and you want
to open the E file black might be able
to play F6 right black will not allow
you to open but what would be the
consequences of this that you will cment
your Bishop on D7 and really not easy
for black to move at all that's exactly
what happened if you moves from now
that's why G6 was not that great Rook H7
sorry H5 and the idea of bringing the
Rook
better all right Rook
C7 yeah and now all all all the ideas
for example this
move this move is now losing to E6 our
idea your idea and if F6 how white is
winning
right so basically this this is
like right well we we we
have yeah I mean I mean if if black
would have played H5 Rook H6 it would
have been less
clear okay so black played
B5
E6 all right F6 was
played yeah black black
position that position deteriorated
quite seriously last several moves but
okay what what did white or how should
white play
here
Rook E3 very good yes
Julian but kind of kind of I
mean yeah quite slow
what I mean he's going to play Rook B8
Rook B6 and get the king out I I think
black want to play something like this
and then make effort to get his King out
or maybe The Rook will go to B6 and the
King out I mean basically King G7 you
have you have Bishop C6 but I'll just
move the rook and then play King
G7 no I Rook Rook E3 I like for two
reasons one it's a very cool move and
strong and two Ben suggested the idea
before what can I
do Rook
B8 no actually here black has a cool way
to defend I mean is worse but not lost
and okay even to many times it happens
to him that the position gets a bit
tough and he's not in the mood and it
just
collapses really fast but I mean what is
white threatening
here what is white
threatening yeah Rook B7 and then Rook
C3 basically white wants somehow to
double on the C file well sorry on the
seventh rank it's called through the
C5 no okay so how can black prevent
it
huh
but D4 Rook
D3 huh yeah B4 and if Rook be3 A5 I mean
okay white white is still supposed to be
better here but well if this you take
the
Rook but less clear white is first of
all exchanging pawns usually I think
would help black he's up material
reducing White's potential for winning
outside pass pawns no take this this
is this is some somewhat better bless
you than the game in the game black just
quite
collapsed immediately but it was still
quite cool way to this
game Rook B6
and finally The Rook made
it H5 only that it was played five six
moves too late no but yeah
plus I mean okay he wants to defend here
but Bishop C8 is a cool
move yeah quite quite amazing how the
Rooks are set in this position and here
one move was played and black resigned
which
move Ben is looking left right before
he's going to suggest something okay but
we'll give someone else huh no you don't
know yes I think
BR look eight what's your
threat to discover
with the
bishop very
good exactly and what should black
play yes Ben resign yeah
resign resign I mean okay was it a
perfect game no I mean probably not but
it it was one very very actually
important game for Theory super
interesting game and I once again again
I mean
no nothing like you know like super
boring you know like getting some
isolated pawn and you know I I like that
position massaging the position for like
moves
okay so we have to show one game in the
benon not that this opening is so
exciting not that the I mean okay I mean
who want some amazing games in benonis I
don't know like maybe had
some oh fisher fisher had some not not
really bad game against py in their
match from
o that they like sacrifice sacrifice oh
no this heavy
stuff all
right it's a fun opening yeah
but okay D4 Knight F6 C4 up until now
yeah so now you play Knight C3 but but
still they go to benon even if Knight C3
you know they I mean because the lines
with F4 are not not that not that killer
lines I don't know just looking at it
you know you know it's amazing uh my
friend my friend and B one of his
favorite parties
friends Timmy Timmy T T Timmy G you know
likes a lot too you don't like the F4
Lin you know like he I think like easily
easily beat sylvano in the same line in
the benon like last three or four games
like no game like I don't know in six
months in one year like same line in the
F4 Bishop B5 Bishop D7 he goes back boom
boom boom like amazing
so but we're going to get here this line
okay so tiny bit about benon fashion at
some point some
point this fine they liked it for white
like Mama
Mia mama mama
mov like somewhere when when me and bang
were young like in the when like 2000s
even like somewhere like that I mean
they thought this line is better for
white and but then some problems with
this with this uh with this move that is
just
equalizing the this move is just
equalizing so this line that was so
promising is
gone and then they
play this move which is not a bad not a
bad
move and the idea is that after Bishop
G7 they play
check and they play this
move yeah and there's like actually one
a great game in this line is Aran
gashimov I think
and Aran played a very very decent
game a very very decent game repti no no
no no no repetition I mean you play you
play Bishop uh Bishop C8 I'll play
Knight B5 and we will have repetition
but without black having some pawns and
material yeah so so so A6 be became more
popular why did that seriously
okay that was not incredibly
impressive yeah
A6
A4 yeah and here they play E3 I mean
what what's what's the idea of
e3 but but a question what would be the
alternative to E3
E4 but E3 is what they like a bit more
why no not really protecting the bishop
I think okay first I really have no idea
but I'm being H more
protection you're
horrible I always think that but I never
say
it you're horrible no come on okay but
the idea is this
one no Pawn to attack on e4
two no weakness on D4 no no square on D4
and no Pawn to attack on on e4 it's like
you know the same idea like in the
Scandinavian you know I used to play
some Blitz with short just kill me and
actually when I played here with aan
like first game that he won just play D
D3 against the Scandinavian and yeah aan
was telling me like oh used to
be actually it's not bad you know like
yeah like and so you know you put the
pawn on D3 nothing to attack on D4 block
the diagonal exactly same
idea
so yeah E3 now they have some I don't
know Rook E8 Queen E7 but Knight E8 is
is main line and like this is kind of
important game because okay it wasn't
very easy to see how to get how to get
Advantage
okay let's see how we
continue but you know one game in benon
that I showed here recently was from the
from uh tournament here in St Louis
where woman Grandmaster Anna sh RIT
killed corales with white like that that
was like a game why not to play the
benoni all right Queen
B3 Rook B8 now a question doesn't it
seem kind of ugly like am I the only one
that this
doesn't it's awful but what to
do
okay where is the Knight
heading yeah but how but how to exchange
I mean the night the Knight has one spot
in those positions I'm say it's unusual
usually
whitechange yeah now this position black
want exchange I'm not certain that that
okay one I'm not certain at all about
this position but I I'm not certain that
wants to exchange the Dos for Bishop I I
actually don't think he
want
yeah don't you want to get rid of the
attacking
D6 but on the other hand like you know
you want to play at some point B5 and I
don't know this bishop
is I'll do
it yeah no no this amazing like like
he's not like doing this he's like like
you know like no that's what's happening
no it's great he you know you always
like to say he the best the but he's
really you know that's that's actually
not funny when we say about him because
he's really the
best yeah
F5
so I mean the advantage of white not
playing E4 remember he has this Square
under control and in many lines this is
not under attack but this Advantage well
black and tiny bit
expand and maybe tiny bit more
expand and this looks like really
bizarre I
agree but but not so
easy I mean okay computer really doesn't
like it for black but luckily luckily
for gashimov he was only playing a 2700
player and not a
computer
take maybe Rook E1 is another idea but
okay take take Rook
E1 by the way computer want to play with
other
Rook but okay Knight
E5 I mean I think that all the positions
that we are seeing and and that's okay
you know that's that's really great
talent and always fun to see like
unbalanced position like I mean okay we
I've chosen four games that you won and
in like I said in none of them we've
seen like I'm certain that he had great
technique you know you cannot really be
top 10 in the world and just play those
positions but still you can play those
positions quite
cool so finally
B5 take take and okay now we see why we
like the bishop
there but I'm what worried about I don't
know something on the E
file maybe not easy yeah Rook
C1 Ben would you take this
Pawn no I what is
that
seriously I play King h8 I'm so
afraid
unbelievable Houdini three Pro don't
have four
yet Knight takes C4 Bishop take Bishop
takes B2
yeah but you know I mean now he says
completely equal best best but I I have
to say I would play second best
move no I would bless you I would I
would not take those pawns I'm I'm
scared even looking at someone taking
this Pawn I would play Bishop F5 I don't
know you know develop kind of looks
healthy no I don't know I like this
bishop out take
take
take amazing take
take and no all
Houdini taking the what what lik taking
the no no but take the pawn back like
all last move so take
take we no mean both players played yeah
this actually mistake for white like
kind of bad yeah because I'm trying to
understand what he's going to play after
it with Bishop blocked and black B Pawn
no this not cool but what black should
play
here color
blind yes white
happy
confusing that is the point though
exactly it's like Greenspan once said
right if he said that if he finish a
speech and you understood what he said
you probably misunderstood him right you
said either I misspoken or you
misunderstood
meop Bishop the is the best move yeah I
mean you want to keep some pieces and
not allow not allow smart almost made it
yeah Bishop D3 but what I don't
understand is why after Bishop D3 which
is best move you get it that goes to why
not Bishop F5 just take on
F4 that that's a good reason right I
mean like just take on F4 and still not
clear yeah I mean I don't know I like
those pawns on the outside like
something like this in my vision I see
like a you know the A5 and your opponent
is taking like two queens putting them
next to
you that's a bit
scary but yeah Bishop D3 had to be
played because if you simplify the
position here no actually I'm not
certain where and what to go here like I
I I really think that just kind of bad
okay probably V was time trouble
actually next move he played it's a good
move I would never play this move never
but
king1 no King F1 I play must be
for yeah here but yeah doesn't look like
the first instinct move right but
Houdini is best move and V's best move
you know those 2700 players starting to
get on my nerve they're really
strong no
that's something has to be done about
it
okay okay push stop push well
attack blockade hey he studied from he
studied from VGA from the previous game
he has experience in these positions
exactly this
move so if E7 want to bring the king I
mean I don't know it looks like such a
okay now computers start to understand
that this is really ugly actually Bishop
D7 is losing move
but okay dude our instincts were not bad
B Queen E6 is a bad move I mean took the
computer okay first move Houdini but no
no intuition no actually S6 doesn't look
healthy okay that position nothing looks
healthy already like this position I I I
really think that just take on C8 is
really bad but I mean the king is so
close to the pawn so yeah pair of
Bishops no pair of Bishops look at the
bishop on
H2 sorry I meant to say like this and
and the king is close so the white king
is so safe yeah white king
white wants to the Queens on the board
yeah exactly and blacking under pressure
and also not exchange the bishop on C8
with the Knight with you know Knight on
e4 but here it's just okay computer say
Bishop A4 kind of only move but already
big Advantage but here just
lost okay you
know yeah
apparently you you know when the
opponent is going to promote and be a
queen up it's a Ben it's a decent time
to resign so I've chosen okay you know
we show decent decent four games right
he beat he beat karnick in our first
game he
beat he beat uh Carson in our second
game he beat ivanchuk in our third game
well one game to De benon which is so
recognized with although okay he made
some draws with really really strong
players
but yeah I mean definitely something
like super set to he actually played in
for an Israeli League played for a uh in
the Israeli League when they play
European Championship he represented in
2008 and N I think for two years so
even some some connection I read some
things on from Israel people that know
him and played in uh they all said like
he was nicest man and always like so
nice to so well thanks to actually Ben I
give him the credit for that and it was
an excellent idea we got to give uh some
respect to one great chest
[Music]
[Applause]
play